Long before he started collecting Infinity
Stones in the MCU and laid waste to the Avengers
in Infinity War, comics readers were well
aware that Thanos is undoubtedly one of the
strongest beings in the Marvel Universe.
But you know what they say: the bigger they
are, the harder they fall, and nobody has
fallen harder than The Mad Titan.
"Who dead?
You dead!"
"you dead, yes!"
How?
Here's a look at seven Marvel characters who
have single-handedly destroyed Thanos.
Drax the Destroyer
"of course Ronan was only a puppet."
Considering he was literally created to destroy
Thanos, Drax the Destroyer has a pretty poor
track record, getting defeated time and time
again.
"You had one job."
But in Annihilation #4, Drax finally managed
to take Thanos out, punching him right through
the chest and literally ripping his heart
out.
Of course, he did it at exactly the wrong
time, as Thanos had just teamed up with the
good guys to save the universe from the villainous
Annihilus.
That's just soooo Drax.
Adam Warlock
The full power of the Infinity Gems was on
display in 1977's Marvel Two-in-One Annual
#2, where Thanos attempted use their might
to destroy the sun.
The combined power of the Avengers and their
allies wasn't enough to stop him, but luckily
they had an inside man - literally.
Contained inside the Soul Gem was the spirit
of Thanos's arch-enemy, Adam Warlock.
Once freed, he made short work of Thanos by
turning him into solid rock.
Hey, he said he wanted stones, right?!
Thane
Early in Thanos' life, the Mad Titan killed
his mother, his wife, his children, and countless
millions more in the hopes of persuading Mistress
Death to love him and become his wife.
Years later, though, during the Infinity crossover
event, readers discovered that during his
travels, Thanos fathered an Inhuman/Eternal
hybrid son named Thane.
In Infinity #6, Thanos finds his son, intent
on killing him too.
However, Thanos is betrayed by his minion
Ebony Maw, who harnesses Thane's innate power
over death itself to freeze Thanos in a amber-like
prison known as "Living Death."
Zombie Hulk
Who doesn't like zombies, right?
Marvel certainly does, because starting in
2005, they began a series of Marvel Zombies
storylines featuring the Marvel heroes and
villains all turned into brain-eating zombies.
Written by Walking Dead creator Robert Kirkman
himself, Marvel Zombies 2 took place 40 years
in the future, after super zombies have eaten
their way across the entire universe.
Among those left: Zombie Thanos and Zombie
Hulk.
And if you think Hulk Smashes, imagine how
much smashing Zombie Hulk does - something
that Thanos learned the hard way when he made
the mistake of getting Hulk angry.
Hey, he did warn us!
"That's my secret, Captain.
I'm always angry."
Death
The first issue of Thanos' 2016 ongoing solo
series ended with the revelation that Thanos,
though at the height of his power to all outward
appearance, was dying from a debilitating
illness that left him weak and eventually
powerless.
So where did this mystery malady come from?
In Thanos #6, fans learned that it was inflicted
by none other than Death herself.
And who can blame her after having to endure
decades of clearly unwanted advances from
a petulant, entitled jerk like Thanos?
She's not into you, bro!
With his powers gone, Thanos was left vulnerable
for a series of vicious beatdowns, each and
every one of which he totally had coming.
"My lady!
Protect me!"
Himself
In the classic series Infinity Gauntlet, which
inspired the hit film Avengers: Infinity War,
Thanos outdid himself, killing half the universe
in another failed attempt to impress Death.
And with the power to control all reality
with the Infinity Gauntlet, it seemed as though
nothing could stop his childish anger.
But it turned out there was someone who could
defeat Thanos: himself.
Yes, old pal Adam Warlock revealed to Thanos
that through a psychic bond, he learned that
Thanos secretly knows he's not worthy of the
power he seeks, and thus always unconsciously
makes mistakes allowing himself to be defeated.
Realizing the truth in Warlock's words, Thanos
helped Warlock regain the Infinity Gauntlet
and restore the universe.
Squirrel Girl
Finally, no list of the Marvel Universe's
most powerful characters would be complete
with Squirrel Girl.
She has the powers of both a squirrel and
a girl, making her unbeatable.
Don't believe us?
Just ask Dr. Doom, or Galactus, both of whom
she has defeated using pluck, self confidence,
friendship, and - of course - the help of
her squirrel friends.
Just how awesome is Squirrel Girl?
In the GLX-Mas Special one-shot, Squirrel
Girl defeated Thanos with the help of her
trusted squirrel, Tippy-Toe, thereby saving
the entire Multiverse.
And in total badass style, she did it off
panel, because it's such a given she would
win that it's not even worth the time to show
it.
Maybe if he had used the Thanos-copter instead
of the Infinity Gauntlet he would have won.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!